but he carol still in a hurry blitzes up
before after king one
he has it all figured out
well he also had plenty of time to
calculate it himself right yeah
looks like it feels like he worked it
all out when he played rook of eight no
since then all his moves have come out
tempo
i'm not sure he's seen everything even
this i think he might have seen c3 or he
should
though it's uh it's quite amazing
so his tenacity is always impressive and
the speed in which he calculates finds
and actually it's uh it's quite annoying
for the players probably because when
you suffer in such an endgame you could
see okay i don't see anything else and
okay i'm calculating i find it i'm
saving it but the guy gives the
the impression that okay
king of faith
this c3 b4 i know what i'm doing fine
okay tomorrow friday i go next
he's giving this expression that okay it
went wrong but okay but i had to
calculate i did it and i just
oh yeah we could see the relief after
rook takes f8 was played from his body
language and since then he really hasn't
doubted how it looks like he's just
sitting there thinking okay
yes let's get this over with
a3 will also be blitzed out yep there it
is
only move but good enough
should see one
and now
is knight before only a movie a2 bishop
b2 would be bad yes so he goes king e2